[Music]
how's it going bros my name is
last week we looked at what was it a
couple's guru
person reacting to me now i was
recommended this video
of a public speaker reacting to me and
now i will react to them
pewdiepie let's go
my name is david jp phillips i'm a pub
god damn it
i've been doing it all wrong
you know this guy's a public speaker
because he knows you need to do
something right away
to get to grab interest mr beast is
really good at this
what's up guys this is emo sixpence
this is what i need to do apparently
just call out something
this is the biggest tampering this world
has ever seen
i'm trying to grow this tambourine to
the moon
from my pippy keep watching this video
alright sorry public speaker man
continue public speaker and i am here
am i detecting a little bit of a swedish
accent on this fellow man
i think yes sir to give you loads of
ideas advice and knowledge on how to
become an even better presenter and
public speaker and we are learning from
the best
it is the absolute hero the best it
can't be me
mr pisa please the king of internet
pewdiepie we gotta ask this question
why is pewdiepie the king why is
pewdiepie the best why is he the legend
why has he got
so many more views than anybody else
he's not driving around a lamborghini
he's not throwing money at people he's
just
him it's just i to be fair i don't throw
money at people
i could do it i guess so that's a good
point and it's been like that for 10
years now i want to have a look at his
first video
and now have a look at that no no
[Laughter]
yes he's still the same guy so this is
going to be exciting this is his first
video
it's so weird i remember shooting that
video even
i have a distinct memory of it i don't
like it pewdiepie here
yeah have you heard that one before
pewdiepie it started off with it kept it
going baby
keeps doing that he's been doing that
for 10 years he's changing his voice
modulating it to a higher register
being that kind of playful guy i usually
take a break from all
electronics or whatever just because the
internet here is so did you see that
beautiful
double shoulder shrug
he's so analytical i love it this is
this is what i expected from the public
speaker what no public speaker
dating guy like he didn't analyze
anything it felt like
no one appreciates my double shrug
shoulder
that i've been i did that 10 years ago
and i was like
no one paid attention to it what the
hell man
that is a very very unusual thing that
public speakers and presenters do
and usually when they're synchronized
that is associated to being truthful in
what you're saying sometimes
really that's so interesting i had no
idea yes i am truthful
one shoulder shrug it can be associated
to not being entirely
truthful or honest about what you're
saying but obviously he
is double shoulder shrug or pewdiepie i
love it
[Laughter]
[Music]
pewdiepie self laughter did you hear it
it's been going on for 10 years
he is still doing it i can promise you
we're gonna have a look at the new video
in just a moment
it's very very comfortable the beautiful
thing with a with a self laughter like
that
is that it increases anticipation of
what's going to come and you think
oh so that's what i've been doing
he makes it seem so deliberate i don't
know
i think that whatever is going to come
is more fun so he is actually
planting fun in that smile
whether you want it that makes sense
actually i
got a job a support captain he's got a
job uh so you can call me captain pewdie
smoke him up in pewter you see that
what did i do now i did a little fake
pipe that's right
genius
[Laughter]
this guy oh my god i feel i feel so
flattered
embarrassed and epic at the same time
legendary prop and what's interesting
with that is that
this is him this is 10 years ago he is
not a public speaker he's not a
presenter
but even the professional ones they
haven't got to this level where they're
using imaginary props maybe they're
using props like this they're showing
something on stage
by using imaginary props
it's not in their repertoire add that to
your repertoire
it'll really enhance your public
speaking you can learn from me
10 years ago public speakers to be fair
like i don't know if he's just uh
buttering me up here so now i'm like
yeah well actually
but i do think that in the school i went
to they
really hammered in on public speaking a
lot
so i do think that helped a little bit
even though i look
back at this and i'm like dude this is
so terrible
oh you can go there and they'll be like
no i don't want to be there and i
believe you better [ __ ] go
[Laughter]
using roleplay as well he's gotten
better at this i think but using
different voices can i thank you
yes you're good now i'm going to go
there you guys are going to go there now
i'm going to go
there and whenever you're in a public
speaking situation use role play like
this with different kind of voices on
stage
oh it's amazing again it's a high level
public speaking skill
using gestures
[Music]
okay let's have a look at the filler
sound thing um
why is he doing it it could be of two
reasons i
believe that he's not aware of that he's
doing it the cool thing with filler
sounds is that
if they are functional i.e you want to
for
some reason make it crystal clear that
you're coming to a point or
that you you want to signal that you're
nervous you want a signal that you're
uncertain you want to signal that you
are super present
then you can add a filler sound
functionally for that
in all other circumstances just kill
them eradicate them
yeah i agree i i i find myself to want
to editing out the
um sounds a lot of times because it is
annoying but i it's interesting how he
points out
they actually do have a point they can
have a point which is kind of
yeah i never thought of that in your
signature scene
why does a man have a towel in the
background huh is that some public
speaking
trick what the it's got this very
deliberate background and a
towel oh oh that that's a public speaker
thing isn't it
he'll come out and be like oh at the end
of the video i bet you wonder why i have
a towel here
well you see they hate them
now i'm curious if that's gonna happen
in your head but
i want to keep uploading videos because
i think it's a lot of fun and i'm gonna
miss you guys
just look at this as soon as he says
i'll be missing you or he talks to us in
one way or another he tilts his head
just slightly a couple of degrees to the
left
we tend to do that when we want to show
empathy for something if your rabbit
died i'll go oh
it's so funny i would never have thought
of that he makes you seem
so smart for doing it when it's just a
natural human thing but he's like look
what he's doing
this is so great that's too sad why i
want to point this out this is because
this guy
is synchronized what i mean with that is
that there are
five levels of synchronicity in your
communication number one gestures number
two body language number three voice
number four
language and number one five facial
expressions if you
are i don't remember single one where
was the diagonal
five when saying something it increases
the credibility of whatever you're
saying this guy is
it's just a natural when it comes to
communication question is
is he still the same pewdiepie then
as he is now
oh god go back to 10 years
ago please
welcome everyone to floor game flooring
flooring
floored and vlogging ah language change
again
after nine seconds is doing exactly one
thing the same as he did
previously in 10 years ago it was
accident
just 10 times more obnoxious you're
welcome people like oh there's a
conspiracy
he's doing it to promote black ops no
i'm just an idiot
okay every conspiracy around me can be
summarized i'm an idiot
like i was gonna private right did you
see that
no i didn't what did i do i did the
double shoulder
yeah damn he's good again
ten years later and i bet we're gonna
hear a register
pitch up as well tootsie's back on the
line so i'm posting my setup
god damn dude
did you hear that register increase
this is pewdiepie for us the question
then does he still have that
synchronicity going
damn dude that's cooler than my setup
that's not fair
this is freaking brilliant you know that
he's three times
displayed a sense of underdog or
displayed a sense of
weakness he did it now that's better
than my setup
yes that is better and all conspiracy
theories around me i am an
idiot admitting or showing a weakness
because i'm a beta i can't help it
look guys he's deliberately pretending
he's an absolute loser
yes of course deliberately increases the
level of serotonin in the other person
they they connect with you in a
different way
that's right you're welcome for the
serotonin guys
i'm so bad do you feel the serotonin
just
surging through your veins i don't know
where serotonin is
is it in your brain it's in your brain
you feel it in your brain
just laying yourself out there showing
that you are so much human that you can
admit your weaknesses like that
that really connects us to him
maybe that's part of his magic spice my
magic formula
we're a peaceful religion everyone will
join and anyone that doesn't will die
okay i'm not threatening but subscribe
no
bell notification come on 11
boom boom boom did you remember that hey
this is again imaginary props
that's my reaction
there is a skill called full out just
playing it full out
obviously spitting on yourself would be
defined as a full out
skill i feel like yeah damn uh first aid
kit you're welcome
saves life this is so beautiful
do you remember the video that he
recorded 10 years ago he had about 20 to
um filler sounds i would guess that
loads of those
were not consciously put there he is so
much more skilled he knows exactly what
he's doing it's like you've gone to a
presentation space
communication skills coach because there
are it's almost like i've been doing it
every single day
i think he's he's on point with the um
times
that's something i found about very
annoying and deliberately trying to get
out of i probably still do it a ton
though and scythe cuts it out basically
very few instances when you can add a
filler sound and this
is one example of those so look at this
he's using them
it's live uh the wrench uh you're
welcome
saves life oh that's true just by effect
just by effect and they're perfectly
placed there i think we've nailed it
guys
i think we've nailed it why you nasty
pewdiepie
such an absolute success one he is
super humble in more than five different
ways did he show weaknesses during this
four-minute analysis of this video
number two you're welcome for the
serotonin guys
two he's got is ready to changes number
three
he's got all the variation spicing as i
call it
which he uses himself he's not just
using visual effects and sound effects
he's using himself with different spicy
words changing language changing
voice he doesn't need anything more than
a camera
a microphone some video editing
and he's got 100 that's right props to
cyber as well guys
and i can just say this i
have been doing public speaking for so
long for 20 years i have still got
so much to learn from now this is an
entirely new arena for me as well doing
reaction videos like this i hope you
like them i hope you love them
but i've got loads to learn from him and
i am here to learn it because
i want to become as excellent as this
dude is
at this profession and career wow
thumbs up to you mate no you're so nice
oh wow or terrible at water everywhere
and ask me
why that person is so absolutely
excellent or
terrible at what they're doing i would
prefer excellent because i love learning
from
great ex
shout out that was such a good video and
not
like even if you didn't bother me up i
still thought that was really
interesting actually hearing a pro and
noticing these things and pointing them
out
that was so cool check out davidjp phil
it's super fun
i was thinking maybe i should do a video
reacting to my own public speakings that
i've actually done i've done a couple
few throughout the years that might be
fun as well
do that next time i don't know that's it
for me for now
see you next time bye bye subscribe
we're trying to reach 107 million
subscribers tambourine will grow
by each subscriber so do it now brofist
met the physical breakfast without any
sort of prop just
imagine me doing it that's the next
level of props
imagine like a jojo stance of a brofist
happening right now behind me
no editing no me doing it bro fish
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean